a child is told to recite a prayer
[Music]
trapped under the rubble of a collapsed
building this is the human toll of a
major earthquake that struck Central
turkey it was felt hard in neighboring
Syria
hundreds of people have already lost
their lives
buildings collapsed across towns and
cities and on both sides of the front
lines of the war in Syria
in areas under the control of the
government and those controlled by the
opposition
desperate appeals for help from those
already struggling to survive after more
than a decade of war in Rebel areas
there are no State structures to deal
with such a disaster
calls are growing for emergency aid as
residential areas are leveled to the
ground
[Music]
buildings have completely been destroyed
due to an earthquake that hit the
northwest of Syria around 4 30 in the
morning the situation is dire and
catastrophic tens of buildings have
fallen in the city of selkin this
complete electrical blackout it's really
catastrophic everyone is on the streets
the buildings are either destroyed or
barely holding here
many of the buildings that collapse were
already not structurally sound due to
years of war Civil Defense teams say
they need Machinery to rescue people
while the few hospitals that survived
government attacks in recent years are
overwhelmed
the medical sector already in north
northwest Syria it's fragile exhausted
by the bombing by the devastation by the
Assad regime many hospitals many doctors
were killed by the pumping and the best
time that we were suffered from the
pandemic coved and after and after now
the medical sector cannot handle all
those insurance we cannot receive all
those injured people are already facing
a severe storm in freezing temperatures
and aftershocks are making their lives
worse more shelter is needed as many
families are again made homeless in a
region where Millions displaced by War
live in tents powerful Tremors were felt
in Lebanon as well they started just
after 3 A.M when most people were asleep
and lasted for at least 40 seconds
there was chaos as many people evacuated
their homes damage may have been minimal
here but more tremors are feared
back in Syria the extent of the
humanitarian tragedy is only becoming
apparent Beirut
Let's cross over to Damascus and speak
to al-mustaf he's joining us from there
he's the U.N resident and humanitarian
coordinator in Syria welcome to the Al
Jazeera NewsHour sir what is your
assessment of the situation so far and
what are your teams on the ground
telling you about what they're seeing
it's a very difficult situation it's a
sad situation here in Syria we have
already a difficult
a difficult situation before 11 years of
war and now nature is even making it
harder on us in Aleppo for example we
have already 40 40 buildings have
collapsed and numerous buildings are
suffered real structural damage and
night collapse might collapse anytime we
are there using schools for self-twin
people homeless people who are already
have been homeless maybe before
many schools have collapsed also are no
longer cannot be used so that the
situation is difficult and not only in
Aleppo and and homes but also on ladakia
and the the coastal area the whole city
creation we have a situation that is uh
not easy for example infrastructure the
the school the roles
water is also have been damaged we rely
very much on the tank water the water
tanks and many many many of them either
need a serious repair or need to be
replaced
I understand that that Ocha does not
provide services but rather it
coordinates the response so how
challenging has it been for you to
coordinate the response under these
circumstances
we have teams in homes in halib in la de
kriya and they're working and we are
coordinating there we have sectors coded
coordinating various various areas of
humanitarian areas we are also
coordinating at the level of Damascus we
are working with Partners uh National
ngos international ngos local Partners
at the government governorate levels and
we can actually we are ready to work and
we are facilitating that there is a huge
need we have already we will have been
suffering
huge needs whether we are talking about
health education or fuel even fuel we
don't have here if we want to address
the situation which is becoming really
serious the roads have been damaged fuel
is not available
staff is not available
hospitals some of them got damaged in
and
maybe in other places we need a lot of
help here so when you okay let's talk
about that help what sort of Aid is
getting into into these areas
yes uh all of us the UN agencies the
humanitarian Community International
ngos the the all the partners here are
using whatever stock where they what
they have we have already we have food
we have non-food items we have tanks we
have uh
clothes winter clothes
sheets but all of these have been
stocked there for the normal needs of
the Syrian people and now because of the
urgency and emergency we are moving with
these we are moving and we are using
them but that needs to be replenished
replenished in the next few days we will
use whatever stock we have medical needs
are huge we are already working to bring
medical supplies from outside otherwise
getting all the facilitation from the
partners to get into the country all
these needs whether they're medical or
others and we're also getting a lot of
support in terms of access to the areas
in the north uh in the in the whole not
beyond the Northwest
Hammer homes
hello
tattoos all these places and if we look
at the northwest of Syria if we look at
the northwest of Syria in particular
last month of course the U.N security
Council agreed to allow Aid into that
part of the country from Turkey across
one border crossing that's the Babel
Hawa border crossing so do you think
that some of the restrictions will be
relaxed now to allowed Aid in and will
the aid still be going in through that
particular Crossing or elsewhere
I think that's Babel Hawa that's the
cross-border from the turkey into into
the Northwest and we are talking about
that NorthWest Plus Halep and homs and
laderia just I want to remind the people
of something halab is only 100 or 120
kilometers from the epicenter in gaziant
and the conditions of halab are not the
same that we are already in a very kind
of difficult situation in terms of the
infrastructure the the the the the the
roads water electricity fuel so the
impact of this is as big as what we see
in other places
and that is I think the problem we have
your question is whether we can get from
this side from halam to reach those
people in need wherever they are whether
they're in the northwest or in this
Coastal area or in Hampton and other
places that have been affected we are
ready to do that we are ready to do that
and we count and rely on our partners
all our partners to facilitate that
access because here we are not talking
politics we're talking access to people
and access to women and children that
are actually going to sleep at night
outside and we all know that now we have
colleagues and we have people in tactus
who are going to sleep hours in freezing
temperatures and it's going to snow if
it's not already snowing in that area
so so have you been guaranteed access
just for clarity have you been
guaranteed access to every area that you
need to reach
from our side from Damascus side yes we
have been guaranteed that access as uh
as soon as is requested it will be
granted
now we need also to have that kind of
guarantee from other partners other
sides I mean Beyond Damascus those areas
that are the northwest of Syria I cannot
and now at this point answer your
question but I'm making this appeal to
facilitate access to those people
because we cannot afford to see people
who have been suffering all these years
again suffer now and actually nature is
making it hard on us okay we'll leave it
there we thank you very much for
speaking to us from Damascus Mr El
Mustafa thank you so much
you're welcome thank you